[Musik]
und jetzt musst du bei der oder soll ich
selber den blitz machen möchte ich habe
jetzt auch ein bisschen angst vielleicht
ist meine hand ab ich glaube ich nicht
[Musik]
altersklasse und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ja ich hoffe natürlich
geht es gut
vor ein paar tagen kam der erste teil
von ich taste virale tik tok live hacks
habe ich selber erfunden die idee das
ist gerade in ganz lateinamerika das
video hat ultra spaß gemacht und ich
habe gesagt mal 6000 likes macht war
noch ein fahrrad die 6000 wurden
natürlich geknackt und deswegen gibt es
heute noch richtig ich habe mich wieder
hingesetzt habe ein paar rausgesucht und
heute wird es wieder sehr interessant ja
ich hoffe ich keine ahnung drin war oder
ich mache einfach ein paar dessert class
der dritte part wird noch heftiger als
heute
für den dritten part muss ich nun
richtig viel einkaufen damit es geil
wird und ich hatte heute jetzt nicht die
zeit und so viel einzukaufen weil es das
hält auch alles doch nicht in einem
laden gibt und so aber wir machen
trotzdem wieder krümmt brutale live
hacks und ich bin gespannt ob die
funktionieren wir sind die augen
ausgefallen als ich das gesehen habe und
ich würde sagen wir aber gar nicht lange
abonniert alle den kanal fast eine
million und bekannte ich habe mal kurz
hinsetzen ich zeig dir mal was ich alles
gefunden habe und wenn euch das
natürlich auch hier ein und wird sagen
wir fangen an mit dem ersten live nicht
oder was auch
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
sagst du das klar also ich glaube das
ist sogar das was ich am
wahrscheinlichsten einstufe dass es
wirklich funktioniert weil das sieht für
mich gar nicht so magisch aus aber wir
haben gleich sachen alter da denkst du
dass das zauberei ach so alles was wir
für diesen live act brauchen ist
natürlich nicht richtig zweck nicht weiß
wem dieser firma gewann mich ist das
technik hat es geht auf jeden fall nicht
mehr schön aus der wirklich gegangen wir
zigaretten kaufen ich habe aufgehört mit
rauchen
ich habe doch aufgehört haben aber
trotzdem ist rein gemacht ist nicht so
schlimm
natürlich brauchen genau tschuldigung
falsche richtung ein
ich weiß jetzt gar nicht ein bisschen
glätteisen wenn sich das hat er mich
dann nämlich leider gar nicht so aus das
ist von marie von meiner freundin die
hat das hier zum glück vergessen und ich
hätte sonst auch noch eines von wunsch
gehabt und zehn euro das ist natürlich
nicht so gut funktioniert ich glaube
auch wobei man ja auch eigentlich sagen
muss als nächster ist egal ob mein
schönster düsseldorf werk bleibt es nur
wir brauchen das geld gleich nochmal und
wenn ich in den nächsten live act damit
zeige dass zu heftig ich kann so viel
schon mal sagen man hätte früher eine
schule einfach ein glätteisen gebraucht
okay hier ist der fünf euro schneiden
das erstmal damit starten bist du bereit
[Musik]
gucken wir auf den knopf darum dass du
noch nicht noch einen knopf im ohr alter
immer geil
ich muss sagen so ganz klar ist es nicht
geworden aber es sieht schon geil aus
oder und das sieht auf jeden fall schon
wieder besser aus als vorher
deswegen würde ich einfach mal sagen
dieser weg funktioniert auf jeden fall
auf meine jetzt wirklich braucht ich
kann mich auch einfach kommt immer drauf
stellen dann wird er genauso naja aber
danach arbeiten nach oben
funktionieren sollte dann würde ich
sagen weil wir ja schon beim glätteisen
sind schauen wir uns auch direkt mit dem
nächsten live ärgern oder scheiße da bin
ich jetzt so gespannt ob das
funktioniert das auch
[Musik]
das
[Applaus]
meinen sie das wird klappen nicht
ich bin da irgendwie guter dinge es
kommt halt darauf an welcher stift ja
ich glaube das geht mit fineliner also
habe ich das verstanden warte mal dass
stand passt dazu activate pence weißt du
was das heißt übersetzt ich habe die
richtige war so ziemlich gefunden falls
ihr das wissen schreibt sehr gerne in
die kommentare
ich habe mir jetzt gerade einmal mein
heft geholt das hatte ich hier rum
liegen und wie man sehen kann hier
stehen wir ganz viele schlaue sachen
drin die ich irgendwann mal für die uni
aufgeschrieben habe ich habe keine
ahnung mehr mit was für einem stift ich
das geschrieben habe aber mich wird
trotzdem sehr interessieren ob das paket
weil sonst braucht man ja mal diesen
tintenkiller oder dieses ding womit man
drüber
das haben wir uns immer die mädels
früher gemacht in der schule nicht wie
ist das nun mal tipps tipp-ex genau da
war ich immer schon ein bisschen
neidisch weil ich hatte so etwas nie ich
würde sagen ich probiere das jetzt
einfach mal hier sonst juni mir gerade
noch so stifter zur verfügung gestellt
die eigentlich auch in diesem video
benutzt wurden also bist du bereit
[Musik]
das hat jetzt schon mal nicht
funktioniert dann versuchen wir diese
seite ich glaube das ist einfach der
falsche schritt erwartet
ich muss jetzt einmal noch hier mit
deinem stifter draufschreiben es musste
auch mit dem hier gehen denn ich mache
ich auch nach unten noch mit dazu
damit wir sehen welches erklärt weißt du
weil ich habe keine ahnung hast du für
stifte benutzt haben wir hier noch so
ein bisschen
einer von ihnen muss es ja sagen metzger
jetzt aber geht der text mal können wir
den text machen hier unten geht nicht
leute aber man muss dazu sagen dieser
hier zum beispiel dass se sein stift den
man dann ganz einfach wieder wegradieren
kann dieser filzstift hier aber nicht
und da will ich jetzt gern noch einmal
testen also ich habe jetzt mal was
aufgeschrieben
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt vielleicht
das glück heute also irgendwie es ist
ein bisschen wild weil es halt nur bei
diesen stiften funktioniert die manet
wegradieren kann aber es funktioniert
deswegen würde ich auch hier sagen kein
fake oder nicht mehr nicht wir sprechen
heute dann würde ich sagen wir schauen
mal was ich noch so rausgekramt habe
[Musik]
da habe ich gar keinen bock drauf warum
die stunden dauern
meinst du das funktioniert wie haben
weil ich habe mir das jetzt öfter machen
druck die hat ja am ende ein anderes
match rapper wendet oder als davor
ja dann würde ich mal sagen wir
probieren es mode wieder hast aber noch
zeit nicht lange
ich habe jetzt gerade mal so eine ganz
kleine fensterscheibe genommen und ein
glas was wirklich hier komplett ja wie
soll ich sagen eben ist das halt
wirklich überhaupt keine möglichkeit
entsteht dass da irgendwie luft rein
kommt das werden wir vielleicht die
einzige sinnvolle erklärung warum das
funktionieren könnte weil ich glaube
dass er ähnlich kraft aber wir versuchen
jetzt einfach mal ist jetzt einfach zur
seite weg nennt erwartet ich will dass
ich würde sagen wir machen sie schon
einmal richtig voll wird maria im video
auch okay 321 erwarte ich mache
mindestens fünf versuche wie kann man
das denn kate ich kenne nur dass so
einer war mir nach türkei in seinem
hotel da hat bislang keiner versteht
hier halt so eine sonne folie darüber
was und dann hat er jetzt so auf mich
drauf geführt und ich so hofer
und dann ist es halt nicht raus gelaufen
ihr könnt ja auch sagen ja mal in die
kommentare schreiben ob er glaubt dass
das richtig funktionieren kann weil ich
glaube es ihnen wenig wirst du von einem
animateur in der türkei für ich will
alles voll haben wir ein ganz kleines
bisschen ich schiebe erstmal das glas
über das geht nicht ich bin auch noch
einmal gemacht
ok jetzt ist juri dran first try oder
leute also ich glaube auch nicht dass
andere glas letzter versuch jetzt mit
einem anderen glas aber ich glaube das
ist fake das kann ich leben
was sagten das fernsehen dass das da
drin bleiben leute dann würde ich mal
sagen das hier ist auf jeden fall viele
aber vielleicht braucht man einfach wie
er vielleicht kann es klappen bei uns
hat es nicht geklappt vielleicht noch
von einem zuschauer schon vielleicht ich
würde sagen ich habe nämlich auch
deutschen live mix gefunden das ist auch
so richtig deutsch schon gemacht diesen
effekt wie das erzählt wurde da dachte
ich mir so was ist da also meiner
meinung nach stellt das überhaupt nicht
ich zeige es nur einmal
weil deutsche live hacks ich meine ich
mache ja auch deutschen youtube co
deswegen macht das vielleicht sind aber
trotz klarer schon ein supertalent sich
ein wenig größer und schlanker zuschauer
outfit im gleichen farbton
ja aber ich fordere silhouetten
unterbrochen den rest zu langweilig ist
der kann dieses teil den trick auch nur
auf diese schuhe anwenden welt marinas
und sind einem schlichten hughes
trainiert zu kleider hosen werden bei
einem optisch verlängern krempelt euro
das ist der einfachste trick um auch mit
klarem schon größer aus was sagst du
dazu kamen fünf zu kochen hosenbeine
hoch erst recht findet das macht mein
bruder mal was zum beispiel wie man ist
doch der tipp für alle influenza system
versagt die unter 71 also für mich macht
es absolut keinen sinn
wie sieht man ein größeres wenn man
seine kriege dann zeigt ist es jetzt der
tolle live act denen wir uns zeigen
wollte
ich weiß nicht eigentlich würde ich mich
auch gewundert dass jetzt ausprobieren
ja ist es schon logisch du willst es
wird ja wohl wenn man seine links hoch
sein wird dass man dann größer wir
demnächst steht die bahn kommt aus einem
zimmer mit oder soll ich das jetzt
ausprobieren so jetzt bin ich ein 20
[Musik]
jetzt 210
hast du tschuldigung ich mache man hier
am anfang gleich umgekrempelt und nicht
umgekrempelt
ich finde schon dass es eine andere
wirkung hat ok na gut dann die deutschen
live acts vielleicht doch gar nicht so
könnte ich dachte es funktioniert als
kurzem beschwört eine sache haben wir
noch gehe ich auch auf jeden fall
ausprobieren wollte und sollte
gehört wollten die rub ist also die
wolken jetzt erzählen dass wenn ich mich
hier an mahle bisschen salz struktur und
bruder mit blitz das fotografierst oder
den blitzer aktiviert das ich dann
schmerzen spüren
also bitte wer glaubt man sowas kann
natürlich sein dass es irgendwelche
chemische reaktion ist aber ich habe
davon keine ahnung ich habe in chemie
zwar irgendwie immer noch zwei gehabt
aber ich weiß bis heute nicht was ein
ionen system ist also wir haben jetzt
auch in einigen geholt permanentmarker
aber ist ja egal ich mache mich jetzt
hier selber mal an dann mache ich das
drauf und dann kannst du das meinetwegen
fotografieren wenn es mal ein bisschen
salz ach so ja gleich gut ist gut
erste scheiße ok und jetzt musst du
warten oder soll ich selber den blitz
machen
ich habe jetzt auch ein bisschen angst
da ist meine hand ab ich traue ich nicht
ich habe gar nichts gemerkt ich mach's
noch einmal ganz nah kommt der blitz
raus
nur nicht recht warum willst du einmal
machen
jetzt hab ich's nicht mehr gemerkt aber
ist das heißt es jetzt vielleicht ein
bisschen ab er ist katholisch heißt
wollen liegt das
google mag wie hat sich das angefühlt es
war sowieso ein ganz kleiner kurzer
stich also es hat nicht gebrannt aber so
sondern als kind einmal ganz kurz so
leicht da rein liebsten hört sich
angefühlt also juli hat gerade
irgendeine reaktion er googelt die da
wohl stattfindet und ja was ist genauso
habe ich nicht verstanden
das war es wieder mit diesem geilen
video es hat spaß gemacht ich würde mal
vorschlagen am sonntag kommt dann der
teil der ein bisschen aufwendiger wird
mit noch viel kassel und live hacks
deswegen abonniert bis dann auf jeden
fall den kanal und wir sehen uns
donnerstagmorgens wie am mittwoch
videopause sehen wir uns am donnerstag
wieder neuen fuhr viermal in alter
frische instagram alex wie danke fürs
zuschauer bereit